bill belichick now you would think a guy
who had tom brady for 20 years hey you
got tom brady
so you really shouldn't be you shouldn't
have a wandering eye and bill belichick
has great respect for tom brady don't
get that twisted
but
jimmy garoppolo in san francisco that
still doesn't sit well with belichick
and i think a lot of people might be
surprised to know just how deep that
affection is between belichick and
garoppolo and the reason is
tom brady had messed the whole thing up
he messed the whole thing up after the
2013 season tom brady's 37 years old it
wasn't a bad season but it wasn't a
brady like season so he's 37 looks like
he's starting to slip a little bit
they draft garoppolo in the spring of
2014 second round pick
yeah springer 14.
second round pick everyone's like oh
whoa
and belichick
that's eloquent uh spokesman made it
worse by saying well look you know look
at tom's age and this contract
oh man so you're really calling it so
you calling this thing out
and
brady messed up the whole plan because i
think their their idea was by 2017
third year for garoppolo
he'll step into the job
brady will be done
seamless transition brady to garoppolo
well tom brady messed around and won
three super bowls after age 37
which is a remarkable stat let's just
pause on that for a second
three three super bowls after 37
and they were forced to trade garoppolo
in season anniversary is coming up next
week i think it was right around
halloween
to san francisco for a second round pick
so mike
they had given him
[Music]
can you hear me mike still
i can hear you i can't see you okay good
so all right i'll just tell you the
story then i'll just keep talking
no keep talking all right i'm listening
i'm here no we still the show's still
going
so they had uh they have been offered
multiple first-round picks
for garoppolo
and they turned them down
and then they gave him away for a second
to san francisco so now san francisco
new england
this weekend
and uh bill belichick is going to look
across at the one who got away
even with even with three super bowls
like you said since then and now with
cam newton
you know under center you think he's
still immense
the loss
of jimmy garoppolo even though even
though put brady got they got three more
rings with brady
they were trying to make it work
they were trying to do the impossible
and you know what what makes us even uh
more intriguing and you know the the
people involved here obviously you
covered belichick
uh you know brady
i don't know if you know garoppolo all
that well
but garoppolo
and tom brady have the same agent
don yee
i remember i know that yeah i know darny
so those so what the patriots were
trying to do the patriots are trying to
structure a contract
that would keep garoppolo with the
patriots
as they
try to do something like tom brady and
and don yee was like daniel was like
what wait a minute
this said this helps one client but
doesn't help the other clients so i
can't do this
so they were really trying to figure out
how to keep brady and garoppolo on the
same team it was impossible and that's
why well that's when they traded him at
the deadline
yeah that's what they were asking
because
you said they were forced to so you know
the only other chronicler of the
patriots that i respect anywhere near as
much as i respect you when it comes to
the patriots is my man seth richard
seth vickersham
that's what's because
yeah like the only person that i respect
anywhere near you when it comes to his
knowledge of the picture seth rickersham
he did a huge story about
the disconnect among kraft belichick and
brady and jimmy garoppolo being right at
the center of it i remember this a few
years ago so when you say they were
forced
like it was definitely brady
it was a brady power play
that got garoppolo shipped up well but
when i say force though when i say force
i say it like this okay
is it a force does somebody say you must
trade jimmy garoppolo brady said i'm not
i'm not coming back if you don't trade
them or
uh robert kraft telling them trent or if
you go to robert craft but
robert craft if you go to robert craft
and craft if you if you go above bill
to craft that's forcing it
and you play you tug at crafts
heartstrings and you're his you know
you're his son but then practically but
see but that but that would mess it up
because now if you're belichick you're
like wait a minute i got your i got your
franchise to like a premier level and
now you don't trust me
so he still ultimately made the decision
is what you're saying he made the
decision but he was forced to because
garoppolo's contract was up
he was not going to resign with the
patriots and you can't just lose him for
nothing
i think he thought that the situation
would resolve itself that maybe it was
terrible brady's play would fall off
yeah which it didn't
that brady uh at that time 40
that he would get hurt he didn't
i think i think you know what it proves
i think you know what it proves that
even the greatest coach in the nfl
history can be wrong
because because there's no way if you're
bill belichick that right now you get
like he now he may believe that he would
have won those three wings anyway
with jimmy garoppolo instead of tom
brady but there's no way of proving that
what we know is that you got three super
bowls out of it
and you got cam newton assigned as a
free agent once brady ultimately decided
to leave so
i think it worked out just fine and
sometimes
listen
the old saying is sometimes the best
phrase of the one you don't make
or the ones you don't make sometimes
the best trades are the ones you're
forced to make and didn't want to at the
time because listen i like jimmy
garoppolo and i'm sure bill was high on
him and you know who knows what he'd be
in the mcdaniels versus a shanahan
offense but like
listen if you talk i don't think
knighters fans
think that they fleece the patriots for
jimmy garoppolo yeah they went to a
super bowl with jimmy garoppolo and he's
had his moments
but he ain't been the second coming of
joe montana on steve young he's you know
sorry but he's pretty good yeah i like
him oh he's good i like oh he is good
you know
if you're if you're the patriots right
now right here right now you either have
garoppolo or cam newton
garoppolo
i don't know if it's that easy i don't
know if it's no no belichick belichick
certainly would belichick certainly
because rather have garoppolo
but and i said here's one more thing on
this mic
it's
you can make the argument that garoppolo
his presence
pushed brady
to say oh wait a minute they bring in
this guy they're bringing in him yeah
they think yeah this is just unintended
it's like hey hey man it's like you when
you got to the boston globe man you walk
all them old dudes up
they're like oh wait a minute i know you
woke me up i was like let me get my top
let me get my column tight here
he ain't coming in here um no look now
i'm just an old dude
no i'm just older that's right so
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports